nous avons la chance de recevoir charlie
les mecs alors autant vous dire autant
vous le dire on va être très gentil
gentil avec avec charlie je vais y venir
à l'autre là arrivent olivier très
gentil et que charlie parce que charlie
son métier elle travaille aux impôts
alors comment ça va bien charlie parce
que c'est vraiment content vraiment
c'était important
vraiment j'ai vraiment je vous aime
beaucoup et dire que je vous ai vus j'ai
senti en vous comme une lame d'une femme
formidable attaque c'est le moment où
j'allais pouvoir m'en veux les moments
volés et tout pour régler vos copains
sur brad que je vous offre mon album
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là
on aimait en un temps lui paie des
impôts québec il faut pas donner alors
si oui quoi que ce soit c'est un petit
coup de flotte les boissons à soda
des cacahuètes
quand j'ai vu quand j'ai vu ma fille
j'ai dit un poncho lalalalalala vous
avez eu élection il ya quatre ou cinq en
cinq ans un accident dramatique dans
lequel vous avez perdu votre bras est
votre meilleure amie va regarder une
petite idée sur vous un cas pareil on
parle de votre association et qui vous
tient à coeur et c'est vrai que ce qu'on
va vous dire après là on a rigolé mais
c'est très important
regardez et apprendre c'est à la suite
d'un terrible accident de voiture il ya
cinq ans que charlie doit être amputé de
l'avant bras avant de subir une
quinzaine d'opérations très lourde
un accident qui coûtera malheureusement
la vie de son meilleur ami assis à
l'arrière pour se reconstruire et lui
rendre hommage
elle a décidé de créer une association
intitulée grâce à la parole de l'ange
pour sensibiliser les plus jeunes aux
risques de la route et aux dangers de
l'alcool au volant les salaires belle en
plus maintenant que c'est plus en plus
facile avec tous les laits des taxis les
machins qu'on peut que téléphoner avec
le portable quand vous faites la fête
qu'on fait tous laissé la bagnole l'airé
la moto prenez voilà après à dax et
c'est dramatique
votre vie a basculé à cause du
conducteur oui écoutez bien ça il était
tellement bourré il avait un gramme 94
et d'après un virage à 160 kilomètres
heure ont été commis à 60 c'est tout le
côté droit qui a appris à louis où il y
avait vous donc est votre meilleur ami
derrière moi la vie elle bascule en a
rien de temps vous savez ce qu on a fait
la fête ce qui en vaut ce pas là avons
fait tout cela fait sierre mais jusqu en
épaules pour ne prenez pas le volant
vraiment c'est le message que veut faire
passer
en fait oui c'est le message que je veux
faire passer mais aussi le fait deux on
peut faire la fête mais la faire bien
donc si on est trop alcoolisés on essaie
classé amis et puis bon on dort même si
c'est à larache si je puis dire
on dort on dort sur place mais on risque
pas sa vie ni la vie des autres ils sont
en face des taxis en a pas partout et
dans des régions comme la corse comme la
champagne ardenne bon bref
alors ils embarquent plein dedans plein
de villages ou des villes un peu éloigné
il ya plein de gens qui mettent en place
des systèmes de navettes
mais maintenant j'ai vu dans les dons
dans les mariages avaient ils mettent en
place un conducteur qui ramène le voilà
c'est très présent et efficace qui a
sonné vous que maintenant j'en ai dit
rien
vous bougez surtout si c'est vrai la
mairie de paris à partir de septembre va
mettre le métro ouvertes toute la nuit
pour éviter de rentrer avec des vélib
mais c'est une info
[Applaudissements]